newly released video shows the aftermath
of the police killing of brianna taylor
in louisville
nearly four months ago officers
conducting a drug raid burst into
taylor's home
and shot her eight times national
correspondent jerica duncan has a video
showing the tension
between police and taylor's boyfriend
come outside brianna taylor's sister
jania palmer posted this neighbor's
video
on social media wednesday night in it
police are seen in front of the
apartment building where taylor and her
boyfriend kenneth walker lived
police are pointing guns and shouting
commands at walker who they later
arrested
turn around face away turn around face
away you can hear kenny saying
my girlfriend's in there she's been shot
and their main concern was not my sister
just minutes before louisville officers
executed a no knock search warrant at
taylor's home
as part of a drug investigation but
attorneys for taylor's family
say no drugs were ever found in newly
released audio of kenneth walker's
interview with louisville police
walker says he and taylor were in bed
the night of march 13
when they heard someone banging on the
door she's like who is it
loud at the top of her lungs no response
louisville police say officers did knock
and identified themselves
but taylor's family attorney ben crump
says that's not true
everybody there said they never heard
the police identify
themselves in his interview with
investigators
louisville police sergeant jonathan
mattingly explained that despite having
a no knock warrant
they knocked because they didn't
consider taylor a major threat
our intent was to give her plenty of
time to come to the door because they
said
she was probably there alone but she
wasn't alone
walker a licensed gun owner fired one
shot
hitting mattingly in the leg the door
like
comes like off the hinges so i just let
off one shot
like i still can't see who it is or
anything
and so i just returned fire i got four
rounds off
um and it was like simultaneous boom
boom boom boom boom
since taylor's death louisville banned
no knock warrants
state senator robert stivers is working
to do the same
for kentucky it should have not been
done the way it was
and under this proposal that i'm in
draft
on uh it would have never happened the
way it happened
palmer tells me that she lived in that
apartment with her older sister brianna
taylor and
that she often thinks about had she been
there that night
she could have died too as for those
three officers who fired their weapon
two of them have been placed on
administrative reassignment during the
ongoing investigation
and one of them gail was fired
and the community's still calling for
arrest in that case derek the more you
hear about this case the more disturbing
it is and the more questions are raised
thank you very much